i liked how it teaches you to break down
problems
and think of the world and i think
anyone who's ever coded
knows that there's no better feeling of
getting it to work right
after struggling with something
[Music]
lee alpert thank you for being on my
show 20 minute leaders it's so good to
have you
hi michael how are you i'm doing great
so
every guest that i have on i ask ahead
of time how do i pronounce their name
because i
i i you know i flunk about 50 of the
names
with my israeli accent usually but now
since we know each other for i think
about like 12 years
i didn't have to do that so i feel like
this is smooth sailing
12 years lee you were at stanford
together you're
you helped teach courses within stanford
computer science helping other students
there are a few quarters or years behind
you with with your new expertise product
management intern
at intuit incredible experiences both in
hong kong but also in greece
working with israel and now most
recently a new program that we'll hear
about near the end
lee i'd love to talk about your journey
and i'd love to talk about your role as
a section leader at stanford and all the
other things that i mentioned but first
of all
who are you lee alpert uh yeah hi
everybody listening thank you for having
me michael
uh i'm lee i grew up mostly between
new york and israel so i personally
think i got the best of both worlds
in that deal um it's
food wise culture wise and just kind of
seeing being able to contrast those two
cultures
that's been incredible give me two
sentences on that the growing up on the
line between new york and
and tel aviv what was that like
i think it was really interesting
especially
you know because of the politics
surrounding the middle east and israel
and
kind of getting perspective on that from
both within and managing to take a step
back
and see kind of the global view on that
i think
gave me a very well-rounded perspective
and and sometimes it's hard right
because you feel
like you're always maybe disagreeing or
you're
always defending or you're always in
these tough conversations um well i have
to say that for me it was always a
dissonance that especially when i was in
the idf
taking part and understanding the
understanding both sides of the story
and then all of a sudden traveling for
the summer to new york and
opening the new york times and seeing
things that i didn't really see in the
israeli news right that's something
that's really interesting
yes definitely um and i think it goes
both ways
you know sometimes you're seeing things
in the states that that you never see
or or just in the international papers
that you never see in israel and
sometimes
now there are a lot of protests going on
in israel i mean i think
voice that hasn't been heard in a while
in israel
is is becoming very vocal and to me
that's very exciting and
and that maybe isn't in the front
headlines internationally and and it
makes sense why that isn't so but
it does kind of help place you in a in a
more global
sense um
yeah i think growing up with that was
very important
in uh shaping my perspectives on that
and it's definitely something i'm still
always learning how to navigate
both with those two cultures and any
others i'm experiencing
well just as a dramatic shift it is to
go between between israel and new york
throughout the years
you went to the israel defense forces
you spent several years there
being with it primarily israelis and
then one clear day you you wake up
and you're at stanford university in a
completely different world start with
that first experience tell me a little
bit about the idf and
and what what was that experience like
for you so
i was a medic which i absolutely
loved um it was really incredible and
i think what i always say of my time in
the army is it was so incredibly
different from anything i had done
before
or will do after it was just so unique
um
i i'd attended an international we had
attended an international school
beforehand
so a lot of people we went to school
with and there was a variation
a lot went to foreign affairs i ended up
um as a medic kind of in a very small
base
in the golan heights by the city medic i
i could
i thought that we would go into a
variety of places i didn't think medic
would be one of them
and not because it's not fantastic but
because i just didn't realize that you
had
an interest in medic um
yeah i guess it was something i kind of
fell into i definitely wanted
to try something new i wanted kind of
that
intense experience of being on a smaller
base
um being on a base where i would spend
bigger chunks of time there
i and i really i really got that i was
exposed
to all types of people i never would
have met um from every socioeconomic
status that was really important
and then being a medic and especially in
the military i think
you know if you study medicine and and
of course i understand why but if you
study
medicine in in really any other space it
takes a long time before before you're
poking someone
um whereas in the
in the ivf you know because of resources
and and just time
it's really you you're just going and
and by practicing on each other and it's
it can get a little gory um medics made
fun of for
starting to like that gore um but i
loved it i realized i really
liked the component of helping people i
liked
kind of the more intense training and
and you never know until
you're really in the situation but it it
was cool to learn about myself that
that i i could handle that and that um i
was calm
under pressure i think that was i even
sometimes was made
made fun of for it a bit um you know
soldiers would come in
panicking and the first thing i would do
i don't ask what's wrong with this it's
just
okay relax like everyone
take a breath and and i think that
applies to anything in life
and and same as really just work
learning to work with limited resources
and making things happen i have to say
so so a lot of people especially in in
around silicon valley they talk about
you know the startup nation and and one
of the things that
that singer and his co-author talk about
in the startup nation book it's this
idea of resilience and the
the quick path to maturity through the
idf and
while a lot of them are talking about
you know the 8200 or the
or the elite intelligence units as as
key factors versus startup nation
people like also eric schmidt they talk
about this exactly you're talking about
this idea that you're being
faced you're being placed in these high
stress situations and at the age of 18
you learn that the most important thing
you can do when somebody comes in
panicking
is to calm them down and and calmly
assess the situation
and and so for me that's a perfect
example of also
one something that i felt that i gained
through the idf but i'd love to also
transition out to stanford and hear
about what that experience was like
moving from putting that putting the
uniform down getting on a plane and
finding yourself in the beautiful
silicon valley in one of the most
beautiful campuses in the world
yeah definitely it happened really fast
you know i was sending in my
applications
um while hot spotting from my bunk bed
in the golan heights and then
within the span of less than a year i
was i was
going from being a medic to i probably
waitressed or bartended a bit uh god
had a bit of time to travel and then
then was a student at stanford
university which which still blows my
mind sometimes
um and and i think i knew it would
it would be a change and i knew it would
be
hard to go back into school after being
out
out for a while and in some ways it was
even more so
um than what i expected there was
definitely one night where
where i re-taught myself what basic
trigonometry was
you know the night i'm still trying to
reteach myself so you're you're fine
oh yeah you know when you hear everyone
talking about how they forgot about
their math over summer
and then they're just nodding yeah yeah
that was three four years ago right
um but but it just been it's been an
incredible journey
i i got so lucky i think just
really met incredible people kind of
learning i think how to make
how to navigate it and make the most of
all the opportunities because
we're so fortunate in that there's just
so many incredible opportunities at
stanford
and sometimes you know it's almost so
much you feel bad that you can't make
everything you can't make every
amazing speaker and i think you know
with time you really learn how to
navigate that and make the most of it
and
and you get really excited and and it's
so cool
um lee give me one thing that truly
surprised you when you came you were
coming to stanford and you're like
wow when i was back in israel i did not
realize that
this is going to be like this
oh that's a tough one i think honestly
for me a lot of it was just
all these interests that i i really
picked up and and things that
oh you know would you have i guess
actually you
you probably knew me back then but i
don't know if you know this but
i think you know 12 year old lee if you
told her she would be
excited by fintech um
or or would have gone to computer
science or some business and technology
was
and get this excited um i don't know if
she if she would have believed you
um but i think it's it's discovering all
these different passions and even
even the areas that you don't go into i
have so much respect
for for all of my fears that i see doing
incredible things
in in other spaces
well i have to say that for myself one
of the things that really surprised me
um was the amount of passion that i saw
so i knew it was a great institution i
knew that it was a
beautiful campus and then the professors
were great but sitting alongside peers
that you know i looked at them as 18
year old
people that i used i commanded soldiers
that were older than them
just you know a month before i got to
stanford literally a month and for me
walking
walking there and thinking of them as
children and all of a sudden seeing
their passion and seeing them as
you know equals and where and we're
having so much fun and they're much
smarter than me
much better than me i think to me that
was that was the
greatest talk to me you choose to go
into computer science
and you go through that track you go
through the systematic track
of of the famous uh classes that we have
in our 106 series
and then you become a sort of a teacher
assistant section leader for that
um yeah definitely and and
i'll agree with you completely on the
passion um
component i think it's inspiring and and
it's people of every age right it's
it's 18 year olds it's professors it's
business students
and for me i i didn't go in
guangco knowing i would do computer
science right i think a part of me
almost
tried to not do that because so many
people were doing it but
i took one course and i took another
and you know somehow it went okay
or even well and and i really enjoyed it
and i liked
how it teaches you to break down
problems and think of the world and
i think anyone who's ever coded knows
that there's no better feeling
of getting it to work right after
struggling with something
and i got really lucky and i had
incredible section leaders and
incredible
teaching assistants and professors
during my courses
and you know i had i've been very
intimidated um stanford computer science
i had no experience it
it was something i was scared of and
then i finally got around to doing it
and i loved it and i thought okay
i i would like to be like one of the
people who helped me first get into this
and
and i would like to help teach this
course i love it
and it was great and and you actually
mentioned that
um you know teaching students in the
years below but that's not necessarily
true it's actually one of the most
commonly taken courses at stanford and
we definitely see law students taking it
too
and it's just such a cool place and it's
great to see what a variety of students
can enjoy this course whether
computer science is their main field of
study or not so lee paint me a picture
because
it is one of the most popular courses at
stanford it's notorious for being
excellent an excellent course that's
been developed over more than a decade
and the year actually that you were
section leading it and
so teaching other students you actually
we changed an entire language right from
java to python which is
which i'm sure was an interesting
transition but paint me a picture a new
student arrives at stanford
they go into the first computer science
class this is an incredible
an incredible experience and i'd love
for you to maybe paint me a picture of
what that's like
and what is the role of the section
leader within that experience
yes definitely and i think this is
something very unique
that happens at stanford and of course
it's dependent on resources but just a
great model for teaching
is that in addition to these very large
lectures
with incredible professors they also
really hire and teach and train and make
this community
of students who will help with the
teaching themselves and then you meet
with students in smaller groups
um maybe about 10 students once a week
to
to reiterate what they learned in
lecture to actually do
live problem solving and for context the
lectures themselves can be sometimes 300
400 students right which is what
people are looking from the side and
saying how can you this is not
personalized it's 400 students
but but the section is where you really
get the added value right
yes and for me i remember those those
were so helpful just getting that
practice as opposed to lecture style
learning which
personally and i think for many people
is a lot harder and then
also when we grade their work we
actually sit with students one-on-one
we leave them notes virtually but we
also meet with them in person
and really go over what went great what
could have gone a little better
how can they improve maybe give them
ideas for
for how they can take this one step
further go beyond the scope of the
assignment
and and then there's also um a ton of
office hours and i think it's
it's that level of feedback and
interaction that that really sets us
apart and and is a reason why these
courses get such great feedback
uh from every type of student and it's
also great to see how they've really
built this community of instructors
and they really value and want our
feedback in how the course is going
both in the syllabus content style of
instruction in order to improve it since
they
they understand that we have so much
contact with the students
it reminds me a lot of the idea of
mentorship where you some where age is
not
the factor sometimes it's like it's just
another peer that's teaching you
material even though you may be
more professional in other fields like
you have a lot like second year law
students who are coming and you're
teaching them computer science and
you're grading their work
what do you tell a student that is just
starting out because your section
leading for one of the
one of the introductory computer science
courses which is the
the beginning of the funnel and one of
the greatest challenges that i know the
faculty and in
all around the world are dealing with
both the diversity issue that
of the funnel it's primarily males
unfortunately that continue
and and the reasons are flawed for that
because it actually turned out i believe
i read a few
a few research reports that actually
females perform better in those in those
courses than males do
so it's more of a social issue but what
do you tell somebody who's starting out
and they're having some trouble they're
they're scared it's difficult
they don't recognize the language and
they meet with flea alpert who's their
section leader
and they look at you as the teacher
because you're the one grading their
work
i think there are a lot of things one
and i
we do talk about this and and how to
approach this problem
i think one the biggest thing i do is
i try to tell them this was so hard for
me too
you know no one gets this right away and
and
also reflect on how far they've come
since they started and i think it's
trying to find a way to teach it which
works for that student because not
everyone is the same learner and
there's so many different ways to
approach a problem
especially in computer science and and i
think it's
it's not giving up and and looking for
that approach that's right for the
student
and i think it's actually really
exciting that you brought up this
diversity because
um i'm not sure if you were part of code
in place
that no not not this past quarter no
um tell me about it yeah it was this
really exciting
initiative that they came together very
fast some
by some computer some of the biggest um
computer science professors at
stanford's and people who are involved
in the section leading program
and they wanted to make this course or
at least the first five weeks of it
accessible globally uh you have so many
people studying remotely
for free for free remotely but
have this style of of teaching
the same idea of section leading same
small cohorts
yes so in order to achieve that because
oh i wish i had the numbers for you but
i know that we had we had thousands of
students and we also had thousands of
volunteer teachers
which was really cool and i got to
actually help train
some of those volunteer teachers in the
way that we do the section leading
and it was great i had um my my
norwegian cousin took the course you
know people from all over the world
took this course and it was really cool
to see and
and the completion rates for for free
courses
um that are in the style tend to be
really low
because sometimes there isn't that
incentive you're not getting a grade you
haven't paid for it so
it's not going to feel the need but i
think we did really well and
and it was such a cool global process to
see especially with this
issue of diversity um being so important
wow okay all that is just fascinating
but i want to make sure that i leave two
or three minutes to talk about what he
did in greece
uh i remember following your journey on
social media back then and it was
inspiring and
and you were volunteering there for
quite some time what were you doing with
israel over
lesbos greece yes so i was a
humanitarian fellow with them
israel is a non-profit that works really
um for they go for humanitarian
disasters all over the world
i was focused on their project in lesbos
greece
unfortunately lesbos greece because of
its location
near turkey became really when the
refugee crisis was at its peak
approximately 2015 a lot a lot of
refugees from all over the world
uh were trying to access the eu through
this small island
in greece uh on the border of turkey and
it was just a crisis it's home to moria
refugee camp one of
uh named in a lot of articles is one of
the worst refugee camps in the world
and i was there um helping with medical
and educational programs and it's really
one of the most important things
i've done um you i got so much exposure
i'm still in touch with with so many of
the people
um i worked with there both both people
who who were volunteers
and people who were themselves asylum
seekers
and how long did you spend on the island
a month and a half i think wow um and
then i i continue to
to stay in touch with people and i try
to speak at events
um about what i've done and it was what
was really neat there and and the big
lesson
i learned there was also just how i got
involved with that in the first place
it definitely remains one of the most
important
uh life experiences i've had and
and i got it becau and i got involved
with it because
um a friend they were speaking at
stanford
a friend knew of my interest in the area
and and just suggested i come
and i think a big lesson i got out of
that and and continue to try and
implement now
and and hopefully always is just you
know make your passions known
um help each other out and then those
around you will let you know of
opportunities there there'll be so much
for you and and help each other out in
that case and and connect friends and
and make all of those things happen
i think it's also inspiring that you
know one of the things that you as you
come to stanford you
hear very quickly is what is your next
internship and what huge company are you
going to work at
and what big name are you going to put
on your cv and the fact that you're
putting that aside and you're saying i
want to first
pursue a passion and i want to pursue
something that i can actually make a
dent and an impact on people's lives
and and only through you know no through
following you a little bit through that
summer i know that you've impacted so
many lives
and so i think that's really that's a
really important message that definitely
people that i talked to in freshman year
at stanford i i try to share as well
but i can't believe it 20 minutes go by
way too fast it's unbelievable but
before we leave i have to ask you for
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
um yes definitely i think
this is this is always a hard question
the hardest we were just reflecting that
stanford asks a similar question on
their
on their application process and how
difficult it was to answer it was hard
then it's
it's hard now i think um i i would like
to
to hope that that thoughtful that i take
time to
consider um a lot of perspectives on
on each issue i'm delving into
passionate
that that you know if you do something
give it a hundred percent
and excited uh just about about all the
things there there are to do and see
i love it lee thank you very much
unfortunately i don't think i'll see you
at campus in the very very near future
but hopefully later on
and and continue doing good for the
world and inspiring others thank you
very much
thank you michael have a good one